hey this is preshtalwalker
in this video i'm going to predict your
number
but to do so you will need a good
calculator to follow along
this can be a smartphone calculator a
computer calculator a scientific
calculator or an online calculator
so to get started pick a whole number
between 2 and 9 and input it on a
calculator
now i want you to raise your number to
the power of 12.
if you're using your smartphone
calculator you can turn your phone
sideways in landscape mode so the
calculator shows more functions
depending on your calculator
there are different buttons that you
might need to press
you might need to press the carrot
button or you might need to press the
button labeled x to the power of y
so go ahead and raise your number to the
power of 12.
you will end up with a large number
we are going to make things even messier
because i now want you to divide the
result by 13.
now you'll end up with a fractional
number and don't worry that's completely
to be expected
i want you to look only at the
fractional part of this number
in particular focus on the third digit
to the right of the decimal mark
now even though you pick some number and
you're far away
i'm going to try and channel the
wavelength of the number you're looking
at
yes i'm getting a strong reading
i'm going to predict that your number is
six
did i figure it out
please like and share this video if i
predicted your number correctly
i would explain why this trick works and
i have a remarkable proof
but unfortunately i'm afraid the proof
is too long to contain in the margin of
this video thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel i
make videos on math you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description